um let me welcome all of you to session
12 and i'll introduce you briefly to
those who are just showing up to my
co-host scott tarrouli good friend of
mine and colleague
he is an expert musician in a number of
different ways and
he both teaches
as a
professor of guitar at berkeley school
of music and he has a number of albums
he does a lot of studio work a lot of
gig work
and he like me is a metal head since our
childhood so he and i have been chatting
about metal stuff for years and years
and years and we thought that we would
turn it into
conversations that other people could
share and as well and one of the the
topics that he and i
have been kicking around for a very long
time is the nature of cover songs
and there's a lot to this topic as we're
going to see
um it seems pretty straightforward and
simple at first what is a cover song
well it's just you take somebody else's
music and you find some way to make it
your own scott and i were joking around
earlier today berkeley school of music
actually has a little
website about how to put your stuff onto
um
uh
what was it youtube right how to take
your stuff and um make it into
youtubeable
things so
that that's kind of funny to see uh
scott was saying well they've caved into
the digital we'll talk about that in a
bit but there's actually
yeah yeah i mean there's a there's a lot
more to the nature of cover songs we can
ask about well
why do they exist um what are people
getting out of covering other people's
music has it changed over time and
actually it has changed considerably
over time there's way way more cover
music out there now than there ever was
in music history and that includes the
world of metal
so um we actually came up with a list of
our top 10 classic metal cover songs and
let me give a little definition of what
we mean here by classic metal this is
not like the definitive definition but
what we're saying is stuff from the 70s
and 80s sometimes people call this
traditional heavy metal
it's the era that we grew up with those
are the the bands that
really played a major role
and
classic metal covers would include then
all these bands that are doing covers of
earlier music so when black sabbath
covers something
by an earlier band or when d purple does
that in the beginning of their career
those would be examples of metal covers
right when judas priest does one that
we're going to talk about quite a bit
diamonds and rust by joan baez that
would be a metal cover as well
i'm going to ask that people go off on
camera when they come on because we're
trying to record this so um
what else would be a metal cover well
when you have other metal bands covering
other metal bands and that could extend
way out into the present time as well
right
because we
we have a vast world of heavy metal that
looks back to predecessors
and um you know we have constant covers
being done we also have different kinds
of albums as well tribute albums are
essentially
what would you call them like baskets of
covers that that's the whole point in a
tribute album and we have a lot of bands
recently putting out cover albums of
their own motorhead did that recently um
saxon did that recently so so this
classic metal covers
covers a lot of
um terrain did i leave anything out
scott in the stuff that we've been
discussing it's kind of hard for me to
remember if we hit all of it
i mean you know we we started to talk
about um
something we haven't gotten to yet but
the distinction of why um
[Music]
well you know uh covering something that
was
by a metal band or something or like
diamonds and rust that's something
that's so far removed from metal
that it's kind of a shock uh but also we
talked about kind of like throwing it in
your live set versus putting it on your
album
right right so one of the things that we
wanted to concentrate on just so it
doesn't sprawl into
an unmanageable amount of stuff is we
wanted to give
bands that made covers
uh
central to their lps to their to their
albums not live albums
not not just bootlegs where they got up
and they played some led zeppelin song
or something like that but where they
said this needs to be on the actual
album
so um we came up with a list for ourself
of a number
of covers and
scott you do you want to read through
the list i've been talking a lot
let me let me get that handy um let's
let's start from the top right with uh
judas priests diamonds and rust
yep
the the joan diaz
yeah um so as i was saying that the
judas priest versus the first version i
heard from the live record when i was
young
um and i didn't know it was a cover song
i don't know about other you know they
so they entered i i mean i ended up
knowing who joan baez was but
um that's a that's
you know it's kind of that's a case of i
wonder why they they chose that tune
you know i wonder we're gonna get into
that a little bit later on yeah
there's a whole backstory to that oh
well i'll learn something
yeah so what about the next one
uh chain of fools that's a head
scratcher to me um if i you know these
are some of the things you're like huh a
metal band
and then an aretha franklin tune um you
know
all i picture is coming to a band
meeting
and somebody's you know it's like a
being in a metal band or something and
somebody's saying you know we should
really do sitting at the sitting on the
dock of the bay
or something like that
and saying huh
why do you hear that why do you
yeah that's what i mean by kind of a
head scratcher now
we're going to talk about that one a bit
there that's a good example of a song
that could really only have been done
by that band
in the current in the configuration that
they had in i think around 1984 that's
on the honor
album um
and they
probably couldn't have pulled it off as
a power trio before
what's the next one
uh mega death
nancy sinatra these boots were made for
walking
which is another
you know
uh you know is that a head scratcher for
you or if it's well the first thing
is a first impression i would say is
this tongue-in-cheek
is this uh or
are they you know are they serious about
it
or you know
the first question i would have is what
was the reasoning behind it and then
listen to it to see if it was kind of a
you know it's like when ozzy does
staying alive
that was kind of to me tongue-in-cheek
right yeah um
wouldn't it be funny if you know
um
because that's such a
disco cultural song right in this case
though it really does work and i'd say
that too about chain of fools like it
turned into really heavy songs
um
there's something about taking over that
melodic progression
that
brought out things that were in the song
but other people
weren't realizing you could say there's
something about bringing a metal
what would you call it um
a metal approach to it i mean help me
out here scott a metal
attitude to it
yeah i mean um
you know you could take the general
chord progression
i mean this is what a producer does what
a producer does is they'll take a set of
chords and lyrics and melody and then
what they'll do is
they'll
put it together so um
you know like a lot of times
i'm doing an album now with a synth pop
uh producer and she'll show me
you know here's this song that i did
it's the more dismal version here's the
dance mix version but it's the same set
of chords it's the same so
essentially you know you could take put
the producer's hat on and go well the
lyrics work in this sense for what we do
or not or so it's like well if we have
some heavier guitar and change the riff
a bit it fits in perfectly with what we
do
so it's kind of you just take the core
of what the song is and then
[Music]
you know you put the the groups or the
individuals sound to it so yeah i would
say that's more of a i would put that
under a producer's hat
so that kind of fits in with the next
one on the list as well then right
and now we're starting to get away from
things that are not directly let's say
rock related
although you know chain of fools okay
it's r b um yep
when we look at judas priest the green
man alicia we're now definitely in iraq
territory but it's a very very different
song isn't it yeah than what fleetwood
mac was doing
yeah and that's an interesting one too
it's just you know you got to take a
band like
make a distinction you know priest was
starting in you know in the 70s
as opposed to a band that started in the
90s that's metal i mean remember i think
we pointed this out last time
before this stuff happened all these
singers had records that weren't metal
or they grew up with stuff that wasn't
metal
that's right there wasn't as much of a
legacy we can say that that by the 80s
um we see bands explicitly saying well
we're being influenced by
all these other metal bands like iron
maiden or judas priest or motorhead
i mean you could say with iron maiden
there's a looking backward to
um on the part of bruce dickinson
explicitly to ian gillen and on the part
of
steve harris to to pete way you know
um so already by
the very late 70s there's that influence
going on
yeah yep
yeah goes go ahead i was going to say
the the the next one that we have is van
halen you really got me which was a king
song
and
uh that became a number one hit for van
halen and it's it's a important part of
their repertoire we're going to talk
about why van halen was doing covers so
much
in just a bit as we get through our list
um yeah that's that's that's a good
distinction right there
yeah let's
let's move on to the next one
um we're at wasp right the who tune
yeah the real me um
this is a this is a really good cover
but now we've got a band like the kinks
where it's a heart it's a definitely a
hard rock band it's not a metal band but
it's the sort of thing that metal heads
are listening to right right
and then there's one that you definitely
wanted in there the white snake song
yeah
right you know because
david coverdale did really
um you know it's a bobby blue bland song
and um he definitely came from if you
ask them he definitely came from the
soul singers
that was his thing so i think those
records he probably grew up with and i
think
you know he
what what was the first white snake
album that was on
um
it was an early well he did it really
early on when you know john sykes and
everything
and um but they still keep it in the in
the second it became kind of a staple
for when david coverdale sings and since
white snake is david coverdale's band
it well it's kind of like you really got
me with van halen it just became you
know
almost a white snake song in the sense
that
well or or diamonds and rust attain that
status too right oh god yeah
well i i think a lot of people showing i
mean
when judas priests are in concert rob
halford always mentions that it is a
cover song
because i think a lot of people in the
audience probably don't know
not now i mean maybe back in the day
when it came out maybe people you know
were
would tend to have albums by different
genres you know they might have a jazz
record they might have a
genres are kind of spread out and you
know remember you know remember again
rock and roll wasn't around that long in
the 70s you know by the 70s we may be
looking at 10 years or so
so
another one that i particularly liked
and this is one where people brought it
up in in comments when we were looking
for you know ideas and information
um
aerosmith has a version of a song that's
been covered by many many people and a
lot of people were plumping for the the
motorhead version which i do like and i
you know motorhead has some really great
covers
i think the aerosmith cover of train
kept it rolling all night long is more
of a definitive cover it's um
it's really it you know and that people
might say well aerosmith is that really
metal
aerosmith isn't necessarily metal all
the time but that song is 1970s metal it
has some of the key traits that we would
be
looking for
in it um you know sort of crunchy sound
there's a lot of great guitar soloing in
it it's got a real edge to it a hardness
to it and i i might my personal feeling
and i'd be interested to see what other
people think i think it's superior to
the motorhead version myself what do you
think scott yeah i mean i i would agree
it became kind of a well you know that's
a tune that people still want to hear in
the aerosmith set that's saying
something
as opposed to if that's true yeah given
the amount of changes that have happened
um with white snake to pick up one of
the other bands okay so white snake has
changed obviously over time but it's
it's it's not as radical a departure
from where they were in the earlier i
mean the late 70s after david coverdale
is out of um
uh um
i'm blanking on it not black sabbath uh
d purple
yeah where he's made his bones and he
forms his own band right it makes sense
that the setlist would stay pretty
pretty constant but if aerosmith is
still including it in their setlists
after all the transformations they've
gone through you know
yeah
and and fans want it you know it's not
like you know um
well let's take a a non-belt metal band
like heart where early on they did rock
and roll by led zeppelin on one of their
albums and i don't know any fans that
want to hear that in the heart set they
want to hear heart songs like they
they're they're not a band that
they did all these led zeppelin covers
but you know
i don't know many people that want to
hear they didn't become part of the band
like the band didn't have a help in
making the song their own or you know
where train captor roland was you know
that's on their that's on their first
album right 71
yeah
yeah so that's that became a um
yeah i still hear people like saying
cool they played train kept to rolling
and i don't know if some people realize
it's a cover but uh you know it's
it's an aerosmith tune to a lot of
people or they made it their own
yeah and it is from a time when they
were probably heavier than they they are
in the you know 80s going forward
well yeah well they weren't really
writing a lot of their stuff in the 80s
um that was dying oh that's interesting
yeah diane warren was writing like the
movie soundtrack stuff and uh
you know you had a lot of famous
producers like desmond child involved
and um you know they were changing with
the times
okay so um i guess maybe like kiss did
um well that's a band that's gone
through a lot of uh blowing in the wind
right
embracing disco
um going to a somewhat
lighter rock sound in the 80s for a
while taking the masks off putting them
back on
um there's a lot that i mean we could do
a whole episode on kiss i think in many
respects
yeah absolutely
now another one that you really wanted
in the list is def leppard's action
which is a
sweet song why why that particular cover
that's been covered by a lot of people
as well right
uh yeah but
notice phil collin
plays that rhythm right and phil collin
for those that don't know came from a
glam band called girl
and you know he wore makeup and you know
it was a you know glam and then you know
he got this opportunity to play
on def leppard's pyromania because the
guitarist was a complete drunk um
why am i forgetting his name
but anyways phil collins only on half of
that album
but
that's definitely i feel like they chose
it and i know phil cullen is a huge
sweet fan i mean you know for the glam
rock stuff it is pretty amazing i love
sweet and when they play it even with
his sound
you can tell he gets it and um they rock
that song i mean it's you know so i feel
like there was integrity in choosing it
on their part and you know
you know it's phil collins you know tip
to his roots
you know clearly and there's there's
something about that rhythm and that
downstroke like kind of punk punkish
kind of rhythm but you wouldn't think
phil collin but like he comes from that
and he can he can throw that rhythm down
like you know like he's
comes from that style which is
interesting because you think of the
album hysteria or something you're not
hearing really any of that
yeah i just thought and i think it's a
great tune and i think they sound great
when they play it it's not like oh what
a letdown you know it's like kind of get
that kind of spirit from it
so a last uh
song on this top 10 suggestions for
great classic metal tunes it might seem
kind of weird to i think some people and
the very first time that i saw it i was
like you got to be kidding me and i had
scott listen to it yesterday because
it's a christopher cross song that's
being covered i mean you know covering
something by joan baez or aretha
franklin or nancy sinatra things that
are way outside of the the mainstream of
hard rock um that's that's one thing
christopher cross is probably you know
the softest of soft rock right so
um
saxon did a version of ride like the
wind and it really does rock it's it's
great metal um it's not the hardest
thing saxon has ever done
but it no but it comes across i mean
we'll go ahead scott i mean so
i said this to greg as a response
because i listened to it because i said
the same thing when greg
you know told me about it
i i said you know you got to be kidding
me
right so i go to it
and it starts off the intro it's metal
and i'm not sure what tune it is but
then
you listen to the lyrics and the lyrics
are metal
the lyrics are you know if you listen to
the ride like the wind you know
you know about this rebel carrying a gun
that's you know gotta run you know is on
is completely on the run for from
authorities and everything and the lyric
content and then i joked and i said wow
christopher cross is pretty metal
you know
surprisingly so right and i think we
could say similar things with what
happens with these other songs that are
being transformed like diamonds and rust
or
chain of fools one reason why i like
chain of fools so much is
as a
you know detroit
r b song it winds up being something
that
fits in metal really well you can set
down a great uh baseline with it
you can solo over it the lyrics
themselves fit in
quite well so
i so that brings us to some of the
deeper questions that we we wanted to
engage in with this um you know what
makes a really good classic
metal cover song and what makes for a
bad one
um how does a band make a song their own
that's something that i'm hoping scott
can really inform us on as a musician
there's a deeper metaphysical question
what is a song as an entity or as an
essence when we say that this particular
song let's take one of the songs that's
been covered over and over and over
again
um born to be wild it's been covered by
by raven with udo singing udo dirk
schneider by the band riot um by slayer
by ozzy apparently with miss piggy i'm
not sure what the context with that was
by bloister cult by crocus those are
just the metal bands that have covered
it like dozens of other bands have
covered it and you know i think all of
us are familiar with it it's being used
in commercials now for people getting
motorcycle insurance i think from geico
so you know born to be wild we all know
the
the song what is and here's where i want
scott to
take a stab at this
when when a song is covered this much
what is the actual song what what is the
common
thread or essence that they have through
is it just the musical
progression the riffs and the lyrics
together and then anything you want to
do with that you can do or are there
limits to how far you can push it with
it being the same song
well okay so if you go to other genres
i take jazz for example um if anybody
knows um you know a lot of the
early you know bebop players and like
even miles davis they just took songs
off the radio
and used that as their
um
springboard for improvisation so and
then herbie hancock did it in the 90s
with the new standard he he covered
nirvana tunes he covered stevie wonder
tunes prince tunes
and the idea is the melody's there
enough that
a layman can understand it but they can
mess with the harmony they can mess with
it you know
the time
the form in a big way but when you've
got metal
the form has to be like you can mess
with it like if we want to go to um the
saxon version of ride like the wind they
put a heavy guitar riff before that
interlude section you know
right
so it
they were able to kind of like you know
i i was like are they going to leave
that out because that's the that part's
not metal but then they ended up making
it a cool riff
on the guitar riff
and um
you're saying like kind of what
what you should consider if you're gonna
make it your own well that yeah if to to
genuinely do that i mean i think there
are some cover songs where you're like
this doesn't really work
as a cover song i mean i get what you're
doing
but this is inferior to other covers or
the original site you know
yeah it could be the producers it could
be but i mean if it's let's take
producers and record companies out of it
you know okay
where if you you it's like tv shows you
you bring the the script and they'll go
you have to take this out you can't put
this on tv you can't do it you know um
you know it's going to be down to
creativity
um
you know like the bands that do direct
covers you know
um yeah where it's like exactly like it
but you know you're not that kind of
player
then it could uh come off as insincere
to the listener i think that's what it
comes down to are you connecting with
your audience on it and it's you don't
have to know anything about music if you
have a band you love
and they put out something that you feel
is insincere
yeah um and you might be a really good
judge a character on this like you know
in the past when i was younger i'd you
know get these albums and they have
filler in it i knew what the filler was
because it's like
we got another week we're gonna put some
silly track you know it's like you know
the beatles used to do it with like you
know you know my name look up the number
and that was just like a big joke they
did for like five minutes and well you
know this is this is a total digression
here and it's not a cover song although
i think it has probably been covered by
a lot of people in bars
warren's cherry pie was exactly that
kind of sawing it was something to
fill up a little space on the album they
had you know they were under contract
and so they like knocked it out real
quick and they're like who's gonna
listen to this crap and as it turned out
that was you know their number one hit
and that's what people still are
demanding of them and they don't like
playing it
because
that's you're right and you know that um
that's the album with uncle tom's cabin
on it which was a killer tune
and that was like you know way below
cherry pie on the mtv playlist yeah um
that's
that's a whole other thing you know what
if
i'm trying to think bands that do cover
songs and that becomes the fan favorite
is may be a little disappointing
yeah
um
i would think even if you're serious
about the cover there's an interesting
comment here by uh jeremiah about sort
of going the other way tori amos's
reigning blood
is entirely different from the original
also excellent and i i got to see her
here actually here in milwaukee
um
playing in concert and she was doing
covers of like nirvana songs and stuff
like that back really 90s yeah and you
know of course it's going to be
different because she's using as her
main instrument a piano and her her
voice
and i think we can say similar things
too like the cardigans did a version of
black sabbath's war pigs which you know
it's not going to be metal when they're
doing it right and so there's kind of a
back and forth that that goes on
it's interesting because i don't think
that
in the
time period that we're primarily looking
at 70s and 80s
that there's a lot of
non-metal covers of metal songs whereas
there are a lot of metal covers of
non-metal songs but then like from the
90s onward we do see a lot of
non-metal covers and whether it be
singer songwriter like uh tori amos or
whether it be pop like the the cardigans
or
you know a lot a lot of um use of metal
riffs in um hip-hop and rap as well
right think about jamie jamie's crying
so that would that would be an exception
actually that's not a cover but that's a
sampling example yeah a good before
things got a lot tighter in terms of
copyright um a lot of hip-hop and rap
was using metal riffs or or hooks for
um
raw material right
yeah or how many times have has um i
can't go for that by holland oats been
sampled
all right
i can't count even even simply red did
that
with with that riff
yeah rising
well so come coming back to this this
question is is there something like an
essence to a song is if there is is it
just the
melody
the
main riffs or you know what's going on
with the rhythm section or the lyrics um
does that you know that's what allows us
to identify a cover as a cover
oh i see what you mean um
in other words
you you're saying we know the song
already
well
you know already but then like what are
they doing to it that's
can it be so different that we it's
unrecognizable that's yeah that's that's
a good question so let's let's take some
um
examples right we do say that diamonds
and rust is a cover sign yeah um and is
that because
the lyrics are the same only half of the
lyrics are actually used in the judas
priesthood song they left out you know
most of the verses
um
it's not because of what's going on with
the
drumming or the bass right
and
there is a chord progression and the
chord progression
but
uh um on the original it's this kind of
cool finger style folk
and they had they would have an
opportunity because i was listening to
it again because it's been a while i
listened to it for this the joan baez
version and i'm like well you know they
could have done like not a power ballad
but they could have done um some kind of
metal intro with those that same
arpeggiation
okay
and then gone heavy but um
you know obviously they start off heavy
and you don't know what song it is but
if you already knew the song you know
when the lyrics of the melody come in
right
so it's kind of like what's this this is
kind of a cool riff and then the melody
comes in you know and if if a cover
a lot of us are introduced to
some of these songs through their covers
um a great example of this would be
metallica's am i evil which was a b-side
cover
that got thrown in
trying to remember exactly what uh
here it is
it which which um wow
it was it was on i think creeping death
perhaps
and it it really took off because
metallica was like going like
gangbusters at that time and diamond
head who they had covered was
you know kind of in in
decline let's say people were not paying
all that much attention
uh to them at that point in time and so
a lot of people got to
learn the song
through
um
through the metallica cover and then
that led to
diamond head getting booed when they did
it on stage
because they they were they had a bunch
of people who thought that they were
just ripping off metallica
when it was exactly the opposite and
metallica had to go on and explain no no
we we've covered this
um
now
after after that a lot of people went
back and listened to the diamond head
version and they've actually said it was
i should go down to this interview they
were asked well did you you know did it
bother you that metallica covered your
your thing diamonds had said well no
that's actually kept us alive
financially because we we get the um
money coming to us from having done
that that cover um royalties are
allowing the band to continue
um so that's you know there's something
nice
about that
um
mark has a good question here do you
think there are different expectations
for what would constitute a good cover
depending on whether it's covered live
or recorded
and i think the answer to that is
absolutely yes right if you're putting
it on an lp you are making a statement
we are standing behind this
it's not the same thing as getting up on
stage and saying hey you like this song
let's play it for you right now maybe
won't play it next next set or something
like that
what do you think scott
no i agree with that if you're gonna put
it well you know in
i i guess it happens less nowadays but
certainly
in the 70s and 80s there would be that
filler thing all right just we we all
used to play this in the bar you know
let's do roadhouse blues
um
and
um
you know uh but
live you know you can get away with it
because you know like towards the end of
the show you know the crowd's getting
riled up and then you do something that
everybody knows and then you come back
with your encore and do two more
so
yeah
so um let's let's talk about some of
these other issues um you mentioned
songs that are bad covers right what
what would be some examples of those for
you
well um
of course i'm a well you know i'm a big
bloister cult fan um and there's a
really famous live album
yeah
called some enchanted evening and uh i
loved it and the problem was it was the
specters tour which is one of one of
their top albums in my book but they had
a few covers on it
and a lot of people hate the kick out
the jams but i don't know why they did
the animals we got to get out of this
place
like that was you know i remember even
as a kid like i'd go to the record
player take the needle off it was just
like really it was just a bad song and
then like them doing it it was just uh
like kick out the jams was the least
rocket and you'd get the crowd going
with it but it's a tune that they didn't
record on an album but they included in
their live album okay so this would go
to that question about uh are there
different
standards different well here's the
thing on that show is the lp was only
about 40 minutes long total but the show
was 90 minutes
so they took out some prime stuff from
spectres that they performed
they took out all this stuff and um they
said well we can only keep about half of
the show
and half of that show was including two
cover songs yeah
now looking back that's like well that's
that's interesting i wonder who decided
that and i should i should ask buck i
mean who decided and they did that on
another uh their other live album born
to be wild was on it
and you know maybe you end with the song
just as a everybody's like you know
rocking out but to put it on your live
album and take out your own original
material
as a fan i don't like it but that's
personal yeah
i mean i think there's a difference
between doing a cover that you've
already got on your lp
on your live album like kisses 20 000
uh
or is it 2000 century man um that's a
cover right so and that that appears
they've got a couple other covers
but well or or you know again when judas
priest does um diamonds and rust or
green man alicia or better by you better
than me those are things off the lp that
show up there
um and they're not on b sites either
they are they're definitely committed to
oh that's a that's an interesting point
i mean
yeah yeah should should we say that b
sides are at like a lower level sort of
like in between live stuff and
an actual lp
i don't know because i don't know in
maybe other people can chime in
um if they can get past sally's uh
great
uh contribution to the
uh conversation but
when i used to buy b-side sorry 45s
um
i'm old enough to have purchased 45s and
the b side usually had a song i liked
better
by the band and then i would buy the
album because it's like okay
but when the b-side had a cover song
that wasn't on the album
that wasn't enticing right
i mean from a marketing perspective but
i wonder if i'm the only one that was
kind of like
uh well the maiden that came out in
their their box set right they had the
the
um
big eddy uh it was the somewhere in time
box that and they had all these kind of
they had some covers they had some stuff
that they did yeah on the album
um
yeah that that's the iron maiden is kind
of a great example there they didn't do
any covers as far as i know on any of
the
lps
but they have a lot of
b sides that are covers and they've been
doing that
from pretty early on
as a matter of fact there's some
where
it's both
singers
so for example um montrose says i've got
the fire shows up as a b-side for
sanctuary with paul diano right so you
get to hear one version of it there
and then they redid it
as the b-side for flight of icarus off
of the peace of mind album by then bruce
dickinson had been
in for quite a while so you got two
different singers covering
the same uh song
mark says one of my favorite memories is
hearing iron maiden play ufos doctor
doctor as part of their warm-up
yeah i mean and again
um that's because steve harris really
loves pete way and ufos so much um so
much so actually do you do you want to
tell this uh
story you know pete way if you don't
know this music history he left ufo
and it was around the same time as fast
eddie clark left motorhead and there's a
whole story about that as well that also
has to do with covers
which we could talk about a little bit
later on and so they were going to get
together and form a super group called
fast way and then it turned out that
that pete way
couldn't do it and so fast eddie clark
did it he got some other people and they
they managed to bring out a couple of
pretty good albums in the in the 1980s
so pete way instead formed a band called
wasted w a
y s t
d you know
typical kind of you know metal spelling
of stuff or you know misspelling of
things
and wasted never really made it i would
even say past like the third tier i
wouldn't even call them a second tier
metal band
they've got a couple good songs they
made it onto metal killers collection
but none of their stuff is really great
but steve harris really really really
liked steve way's work and kind of
looked up to him and
so now here's where i'm going to turn it
over to scott because he got to see some
of the fruits of this
so um
i'm gonna i'm gonna go back to the part
you haven't heard um okay
so
i was in high school at the time this is
86 when somewhere in time came out
and um
a science teacher was going to
demonstrate how
a needle worked so we all took like a
threading needle and
you know just a paper cone and we'd spin
a record and play it and it was a wasted
record i've never heard of it so i'm
trying to listen to it but we kind of
like being mischievous we got into his
back room and he had a stack of wasted
albums wow and it turns out that like
his
nephew or something had to do with road
crew or something so so my friend and i
each took one so i listened to the band
and they were like i would say it was
kind of more like survivor
it was like really cool pop rock yeah
and um but i'm like pete way from ufo
that doesn't work i show up to see the
maiden show maybe a month later and
wasted his opening
and i'm like oh this is cool you know i
like these songs right
it's like third song in and they're just
being booed the whole time oh yeah and
um then they left stage and steve harris
came out and like read the riot act
and you know he was just like that's a
legend and you know he's
you wouldn't have me if it wasn't for
him and it was you know at the time i
was just like oh my god like what's
going on and everybody got quiet you
know and then
you know but um
yeah
it's it's it was unusual it's great that
he came out just to do it rather than
bruce who you'd expect to come yell at
everyone yeah because i've had bruce you
know bruce has yelled at the crowd many
times and i'm on his side most of the
time you know he's an airline pilot and
people are smoking pot but he has to
take drug tests to be an airline pilot
and if they find pot in his system
yeah
i'll actually i'll go on a digression at
monsters rock and this would have been
1988 when i was just
graduating from high school it was in
alpine valley and alpine valley
is one of those outside music venues
that
fell onto hard times like went under for
a while now it's back again
and in the 80s it was like the place to
go see bands because it was in a valley
a natural valley so there's like a you
know an actual band shell with all the
seats and then there were all these lawn
seats and there were there wasn't a
single bad lawn seat you could actually
see quite well
and people would get drunk and high and
you know all sorts of things going on
and
monsters of rock is a long thing right
it was
i forget who the opening band was but
they almost got booed off the stage
because we wanted to see the others
um
it wasn't it might have been kingdom
come
um but then it was like you know
metallica the scorpions um dawkins
yeah and then finally it was van halen
and there was like a little bit of a
delay or something and people were
throwing around beach balls and so that
that's cool and then people started
pulling up sod like big giant pieces of
sod
you know this thick and throwing them
around
and and so the concert venue was not
happy about that but you know it's rock
and roll right um but then people were
getting hit in the head with these these
giant pieces assad and so sammy hagar
came out he was like yelling at the
crowd and you know this is not the way
to you know to rock and roll and and
stuff like that and people are like who
the hell are you to tell us
what rock and roll is you know you're
you're you know kind of getting uh
what would be the you know you're you're
out of touch right
um and to you know sammy hagar had been
around for quite a long time you know uh
he was he was rocking with montrose
before van halen were even organized as
a group right um
but that was kind of funny to see him
haranguing the crowd you know there's a
certain tension that gets set up when
when that happens
yeah i mean uh
the whole well the somewhere in time
tour i'll never forget
walking through and iron maiden had put
signs everywhere
pleading with the fans not to destroy
anything oh interesting and it was kind
of like you know if you want us to come
back to your town you won't destroy the
bathrooms you won't spray paint you
won't throw seats you won't throw beers
at people and i remember at that time
just going wow i mean they must have
threats from venues going you know if
your audi we won't bring you back but i
remember being like every two feet at
the merch stand where the bathrooms were
going into the venue yeah
so that's uh
but you know i i've never known do you
have you ever known iron maiden to do a
cover song live
i've never seen it um but that that
certainly doesn't mean that it doesn't
happen um but
this is a good point there are some
bands who do a lot more cover stuff and
there's a lot of bands who
who don't and and some of it could be
just a temperament they don't want to do
it they've got enough material in their
catalog
but some of it could also be
how they
developed you know so if we take van
halen for example
before van halen really made it big they
were one of the best cover bands in the
la area
and they that's how they in fact made it
big that's how they made a lot of money
that's how they
drew audiences they would be in these
parties and they would be expected to be
doing cover songs
and they had to fight to get their own
material um in there and and some of the
venues that they would go to
were cool with them playing their own
original material and some of them were
like you're not here to play house
what is the house of pain was
or
one of their early ones of course you
know running with the devil things like
that
i mean these guys put together a 25 song
demo
when they were invited to do it so they
clearly had a vast range but
um they were
worried about getting pegged as a band
that was only going to do covers
but you know look at what they chose to
make one of their first singles
a kink song
which now let me ask you scott um do you
think the van halen version is actually
better than the kinks
version or would you say they're about
the same or would you say the kinks
version is better uh that's a tough one
because
that's an example of
it it's still van halen it's a king song
but it's it's i mean you know mostly
eddie
there's no mistaking eddie well david
lee roth's voice right or david lee
roth's voice so yes it's a cover but it
you know the reason it wasn't played on
the radio all the time and it would be
still played on classic rock stations
it was so
them it was it didn't sound like
contrived and you know it fit in with
the rest of the album how it was
recorded it didn't sound like it was
recorded on a different day with
different gear or yeah you know it just
kind of sounded like
part of their session
and they did it convincingly this goes
back to that that thing about bad cover
songs um
and one of the ones that i think is
particularly egregiously bad is judas
priest johnny b good oh god stop um and
it fits all the criteria that you were
just talking about it you know does it
sound like them yes it sounds like them
but it sounds like them screwing off and
playing something that
doesn't fit at all they they didn't make
it their own or if they did they made it
their own in ways that just didn't
didn't come across you know
yeah um and like you know jeremiah has a
good point guns and roses too you know
relying on covers but you know what's
funny about that is
i totally agree with that because um
after appetite
did so well i think what happened is the
record company said okay
you have three months to make a new
album um and that might have been been
something and two of them got consumed
with partying
well you know they they took pride in
showing up two hours late
um
you know that's that's just yeah of
course you know i wonder because i know
bands were like well we know kiss you
know ice wouldn't show up to the
sessions yeah drunk passed out somewhere
so robin ford's playing on some of the
albums or
um but you know uh
and i you know
i didn't even think about guns and roses
because we could consider them they're
more like
uh do we consider them metal i mean
they're metalish riffs but they're kind
of like in the tradition of aeros 70s
aerosmith i mean they were they were
what was getting called metal in the
late 80s so
i would say so
i would say so and the first album i
thought was great but
you know their covers were
were pretty bad you know you know like
live and let die was like you know even
we came on empty but why
why are you doing live and let die you
know well this this brings up a good
point do you think there's some bands
that whose music is harder to cover i
mean another great beatles
um hard edge thing is is helter skelter
right and motley crue's um helter
skelter on shout out the devil it's
pretty good
it doesn't make it into like that top
tier of
metal covers i would say
it definitely sounds like them but it
sounds like all the other songs i would
say on that album which is is in fact
you know that's where i think motley
crue is making their best music
um
yeah shout out to the devil yeah
i mean what they did on the next album
with smoking in the boys room i would
say is more theirs
than that beatles song that they were
doing
you know i remember they had a huge hit
with smoking in the boys room and that
was on the radio a lot and i remember
right yeah cover metal bands like in
high schools were all doing the
the crew version of that tune
and that was kind of like you know to
kids in high school that was a crew tune
as far as they
they're concerned you know they know
with a song for the 50s or whatever
right right yeah
um i mean that is that is an issue that
comes up with with uh
this whole phenomenon of covering is how
do fans i mentioned the metallica and
diamond head thing how do fans get to
know
who actually
um
originated the song
well you know back with vinyl at least
when we bought tapes and vinyl when we
listened to the album you know it wasn't
on in the background as much as you know
if somebody puts their phone on in the
background but you know we often read
through the thing and it would say who
wrote it
or you know or you notice if it was like
a different publishing company because
every publishing company has different
names
so sometimes you know you'd get the
record and you're looking like no
kidding it's not their song
and you know um
they would always say
um if there was a guest musician
you know um courtesy of columbia records
but this is an epic epic records album
yeah yeah a lot of times if you had the
um
and sometimes in the liner notes they'd
say you might notice the inclusion of
whatever
um
it's harder to tell these days with the
digital age i guess
but uh well it's harder and easier in a
way because
when we would get like an album or a
tape and it would have somebody else's
names as the writers if you didn't know
who the hell these people were you
wouldn't associate them with the band
that it came from and you would have to
do some
digging around you know without the
internet there to like immediately
google
who brian tatler is you wouldn't know um
that a song is by diamond head right you
just know it's this guy
tattler and metallica's covered it so
who who's this you know
um
whereas now
there's lots more there's a lot more
covers and we can easily
look up the information but i think
there's also like quite a few people who
hear covers
and they don't realize that they
actually are covers because they don't
know we could call it the canon or
whatever fancy term we want to have for
having had a long you know uh listening
history if somebody's you know 18 years
old
you can't expect them to have had the
listening history of somebody who's 40
years old right
that yeah well look like i said when i
was younger i thought you know that uh i
thought uh the joan baez song was a
priest song when i was younger
you know
you know like
because it sounded like them it's not
like they tried to do the same right
yeah yeah well actually so i i do have
some things that i i dug up
um about that particular song so i'm
going to read some of this to you
halford in an interview is saying it's a
vivid memory
here's the thing judas priests were just
starting to get some kind of traction in
america and the label had suggested to
us we might want to consider doing a
cover song to see if we could make some
kind of entrance into the glorious
american rock and roll radio scene
so priest then and priest now has always
been very open-minded to any opportunity
to spread the gospel of judas priest
medal so we said yes send anything and
we're ready to hear whatever you've got
so that sounds pretty good so far right
you know
plausible uh market strategy yeah so
they send diamonds and rust
he says the first time we heard that
song we're in a little studio in south
wales this 45 single came in the mail
registered delivery from the label this
is the labels idea that they should they
should cover this song
we take it out there it is a 45 single
joan joan baez diamonds and rust we go
into the studio and open up an old
record player and put the single on the
top and press start and watch it drop
and the needle go and then the music
starts now bear in mind we all know who
joan baez is we're all aware she's a
very very famous lady famous musician
famous activist but we have no idea
what's going to come through the
speakers so when we first hear joan
simply joan and her acoustic guitar
singing the opening lines all be damned
here comes your ghost again we all
looked at each other and the initial gut
feeling was this can't be right this
isn't heavy metal how can this be turned
into a heavy metal experience
but then as the song moved on i think it
was a like a bit of epiphany for judas
priest because at that moment we
understood that a great song as is the
case with joan baez diamonds and rust
will take any kind of translation
any kind of changing direction changing
sound however you want to describe it
so then it became for us
a real fun interesting experience of
taking this very beautiful
very fragile song and making it into
this big metal monster which it still is
for for a judas priest
that's a very interesting set of
observations on helford who's you know a
smart guy
on his part that maybe there's some
songs not all songs but some songs where
they have enough malleability there's
enough
something there that can be turned into
something else
you know and again i would say that what
tank did with chain of fools
uh fits that bill um saxons ride like
the wind you know um well i think that's
a perfect translation that tank because
you know the lyrics
alone
and the progressions you know
the the the progression that you just
changed the groove a little bit
you know but they didn't have that you
know that keyboard riff they just had
the cords with a metal but i think it
was a it was like a gallop right yeah
basically you put the metal gallop and
um the rhythm of the melody fit fits a
gallop groove just fine so you've got
the little content and you've got you
know the chord progressions not
something that it wasn't like
you're a little you're a little frozen
on my end
so
i'm going to take this this moment uh
well scott is uh sorting out the
internet stuff on on his side to mention
that um
the tank thing i i said earlier probably
couldn't have been pulled off
by the tank that was the original
bandwidth which was a power trio
algae ward being the key person involved
there
the brobz brothers ended up leaving and
then you have
um
uh
cliff uh evans and uh mick tucker coming
on as twin guitars
and you probably needed that in order to
make it work oh it looks like we might
have lost scott due to internet issues
for a bit so we'll see if he comes
back in or not and that's a prime
example of a band that could only cover
at a certain point could only translate
that song into something at a certain
point and we might say similar things
about van halen maybe you know the van
halen with david lee roth there's
certain things that they
could pull off and then there's other
things that they they couldn't pull off
with
sammy hagar or anybody else later on
maybe losing michael anthony would also
be
something that would erode the ability
to do
covers like that
so those are all
significant issues i would say
[Music]
let's see if we can get scott back in
here i don't see
camera for there we go
all right yeah he kicked me off so
yeah the internet gods uh are capricious
and cruel sometimes
so i was just talking a little bit more
about that tank sewing and then i spun
off into thinking about you know um
other bands that maybe couldn't have
pulled off a particular cover at a a
given time you know like which was
priest i think that we could say
the the whole era they could do the
covers
but maybe some bands the covers wouldn't
well we talked about aerosmith right
train kept it rolling that can be done
the way it was done in the 70s when
they're taking so much direction from
other people whether songwriting or
production
maybe they can't right
well you know it's interesting
um well let's take somebody trying to
cover judas priest
okay
that's a bit of a challenge because rob
halford has such a unique voice and a
such a unique way of phrasing that the
melodies that he comes up with really
sued his voice or the band
um
or
yeah i mean it's uh
like i've
i've played shows with priest songs with
good singers but it just wasn't the song
to me
okay so you know i've been in situations
where like this is not the band to cover
a priest song now why why not can you
like peel back the curtain a little bit
on that or
um
if it's you know
part of the charm is hal halford sings
but
if you're not going to do that you're
going to have to put work into going
this is a great song
um
you could use somebody with a different
voice so they're going to have to have
to have a
maybe a unique strength on their own
okay obey this um
let's take like okay so take a band like
dire straits mark knopfler you know it's
kind of mumbling but he's singing but
you know if you're gonna have uh
a clear uh song of it it wouldn't it
wouldn't come across that well well i
mean like if if judas priests wanted to
do brothers and arms or money for
nothing okay i mean that would be kind
of might be funny i mean i you know
you're taking something that's so
characteristic to that song like that
part of the charm of dire straits is
that scottish blue collar kind of
you know
uh
sentiment and ethos yeah
exactly that's the word i'm looking for
and
you know uh that's why i think the tank
one works great just to add to our to
tie back
um bad covers i think one of the top
bad covers is scorpions can't explain
now why i mean i don't think it's a
terrible cover i just think it's
mediocre
oh
why do you think it's terrible
they write such great stuff and they're
first of all doing a cover song i mean
that was in what the was that the early
90s mid 90s yeah when they did that they
weren't writing great stuff then but it
was just kind of like and then they
pushed it as a single
because like and but it didn't really
catch it never caught and i'm thinking
you know
here we are like you know you and i you
know fans of uh love of first sting or
love drive or or worldwide live which i
wore out and then you you see the
scorpions trying to push a bad version
of can't explain
um
yeah
uh
maybe they would have gotten away with
it if it was earlier in their career
like the you know that we want to kind
of do a crossover thing
but it would have had a different sound
to it though that that so again like
different versions of the band the
scorpions lineup didn't change
um going from the 80s to the 90s but
their sound did change
yeah um savage amusement is it's okay as
an album there's some good songs on
there but it's not blackout it's not
um love at first sting it's not love
drive it's not
um you know like you mentioned the the
energy of worldwide live it just sounded
like a tired album and a lot of their
stuff since then just hasn't had the
the energy and vitality of uh the
earlier stuff the hunger you know i love
savage amusement but here's what changed
with that is for the first time they
were playing with the 80 sounds on their
guitars
and you know it's kind of interesting so
anything before that was just straight
through the marshall
and
so i'm you know i used to think you know
at the time i loved it and i didn't
notice it because you know guitar sounds
like that were all around me in that era
or all around us yeah um i
i would like to hear those songs done
just through the marshalls the old way
because a lot of them have a good energy
a good i thought it was a strong album
but the one after that where it was um
you know it was kind of like the
tired ballads what was the album was it
1990 what what am i thinking of with uh
the winds of change yeah that's the only
song i really remember off of it and
when i heard that i was like ooh this
you know i get why they're doing it
given the world historical moment that
they're in but
this is
this is definitely not metal
and you remember this is the era where
the mtv was starting to say you need to
do the acoustic jam well that's right
yeah yeah so it was kind of like i
thought queens like reich was amazing
their songs
transferred to acoustic great because
the melodies were great the progression
so you could take away the loud guitars
and i thought they were one of the best
ones but then you take someone like
poison you can't take away
the kind of
new york dolls punk rock thing because
yeah that's what it's about and that
dirty guitar sound
yeah yeah and cece was great at that he
wrote great you know pop punk tunes i
mean he he wrote a lot of the um
levine songs he ghost wrote for a lot of
those kind of people and um but like you
know you took a lot of those bands and
then you know first of all they weren't
good acoustic players
and but some of the bands did it but
that was the era that like bands were
trying like it was after the power
ballad but in the acoustic jam part like
tesla was the first one to do it i think
the five mana cube that's right yeah
yeah
and i think that that did well so
everybody you know mtv said this is it
we're gonna have everybody do acoustic
for you know
acoustic jams in it well they insisted
on that not just for metal bands but
also i remember like stone temple pilot
had had their version of creep that was
acoustic and
nirvana didn't they do like an unplugged
version they did some other stuff yeah
so i think everybody had to do
unplugged unless you're a
singer-songwriter and you're already on
you're already doing it
yeah that was that was not a great era i
mean it was a
but like queen break i remember i've
seen that thinking how great it it was
and i listened to it a couple of years
ago thinking
great great songs you know
there are songs that can stand up to
just singing with an acoustic guitar
well mentioning uh
queens reich is a good opportunity to
shift to something else that we were
going to talk about in this which is
cover albums which are a
a more recent phenomenon i mean
going back in the day like if you look
at the very first deep purple and black
sabbath albums they both contain covers
and it was kind of a
thing back then to have at least a
couple covers so same thing with ufo by
the way their early stuff had a couple
covers on it as well
but
cover albums an album where you're just
covering other people's stuff wasn't
being done so much in metal
at that time i think there were other
people who were doing that and it's
become a big thing you could say like in
the last
10 years or so um
there's some that are kind of hard to
say whether they really are cover albums
or not like for example twisted sister's
christmas album should we consider that
to be a cover album probably not i mean
it's a metal album
they are covers
are they really
metal covers i i don't know but but
they're i'll just read you the list of
some of the recent ones right so there's
the fawzi album from 2000 which is you
know a kind of made-up band
that's supposed to have gotten like
stuck in japan and could never get out
of there it's actually like a super
group that was doing that project and
most of their stuff is is covers
um raven recently did party
animals which was part of their
kickstarter project it was an extra
thing overkill did a
album called coverkill queens reich did
take cover you're starting to see a
theme now right in the naming of them
ozzy did undercover motorhead did under
if we pronounced it with the umlaut that
it has under cover but it's actually
undercover
saxon recently brought out something
called inspirations which is all cover
tunes as well
iron maiden has one that's called best
of the b sides
now this is a good one to debate so it's
not all cover material it the a lot of
the b-sides are covered material so
bringing to get them together
along with some original songs is that
really a cover album or not
um what do you think does it have to be
all covers to be a cover album
or well it doesn't sound like the iron
maiden's a dedicated cover um so like
you pointed out cover kill yeah
you know undercover so these are
clearly we've set out to do but when you
take all your b sides and the b sides
happen to be covers okay so that's an
important distinction yeah it's like a
byproduct the cover forms are a
byproduct of the b-sides being cover
songs it has to do with something like
intentionality or
i would say so because that's a big deal
when you do a covers album rather than
filling your out your album of originals
with two covers
at least we know what you set out to do
when you did that record you know and
i'll point out that a lot of these
recent covers are the bands having a fun
time you know saying oh we we really
like these songs that's why we're doing
them so like motorhead their undercover
has um you know stuff like david bowie
on it um
or you know
other things that are not not metal
oriented here's a good one for you
um so white snake their purple album
that is deep purple covers
but david coverdale was a member of deep
purple
right is it a cover album or not is it a
cover album
um the rest of the band aren't members
of deep purple only only david coverdale
but he is the band leader
so
but he wasn't the bandleader of deep
purple
no and i'm wondering you know it's a
good question i should look into it did
david coverdale have writing credits
in those songs he covered for the album
in other words our purple fans gonna
race out and buy it and there's gonna be
money in his bank account because
so the answer to that is
yes for some of the songs but not the
majority of them
oh really so he he did some songs that
he didn't sing on and albums he wasn't
on yeah
he like covered a wide range of stuff
from deep purple mark ii mark iii and
mark iv
oh
you know and it's funny because uh
i remember that coming out and having no
interest in getting it
um
why was that
because i'm thinking like you know um
there's times that you know and i could
be wrong people might disagree with me
there's times i look at it okay okay
that was lazy
you know that was like you know uh you
put this album together
you know everybody that band knows the
purple standards you go in and you knock
it out in a couple days okay you know um
you know didn't write new material
although so so that's interesting
because one could say that doing a cover
album by itself is kind of lazy
because you're taking other people's
things that have already been written
you don't have to go through the
songwriting process
you're saying it's even in some respect
lazier because these are your own
standards already
right
or am i misinterpreting you oh you're no
you're you're right and um
you know here's the other thing because
there's a trade-off you know these bands
you know i know toto's not a metal band
but they did a covers album and
my first question is well you're going
to spend money putting this album out
and you will make no money from it
because you don't own the licensing you
don't own the songwriting you don't own
anything to do with these songs so like
when you know
halloween does a cover album every album
they sell the money goes to the people
that wrote the song or on the publishing
so i'm always interested you know in
this day what's what's the motive for
doing covers
for doing a covers album and there's an
answer that i don't know and i'm i
should ask
some of the people that have done that
in their position why'd you do a covers
album like you know oh it's fun yeah but
it cost you money
you know it cost you money and you put
you know maybe
maybe you want money to go into the
pockets of your influences that's cool
um
yeah in the case of white snake it's you
know
at least some of it when he sells the
full album
coverdale if he had writing credits and
owns publishing he's going to make money
from it i mean i think you could say
that about one of the early cover albums
in the classic metal era which would be
metallica's garage days revisited right
um
they were and lars ulrich who is not a
upstanding great individual you could
say from all sorts of perspectives i
mean to his credit
um
he was the one who was really pushing
going back and looking at all these at
that time rather obscure and things
hadn't worked out for them new wave of
british heavy metal acts like blitzkrieg
or diamond head
um
budgie i guess you could say was doing
well they covered one budgie sewing on
that but budgie had also kind of kind of
slipped into obscurity so they they were
it was doing kind of double duty it's
well triple duty right it's they get to
play a song that has been formative for
them that they think is a good metal
song a good standard
um they get to redirect attention back
to these uh bands that
haven't made it
and they also get to funnel some money
to them you know like like we're saying
am i evil
um
made diamond head more money as a
metallica song that ever made that was a
diamond head song right so
um like i said the paychecks went to
them
um because they owned so every time
metallica sold an album or that or a
download of that song or whatever
they end up they end up getting uh
diamond head ends up getting the money i
suppose i mean i don't want to get too
far into the weeds and finance stuff but
you know
if you're producing a cover thing
you can write off your salary to produce
it and the time in the studio and
whatever you have to buy as business
expenses right so the the musicians are
getting not the gross but the net
uh from it
so so you could pay yourself a good
amount of money to like make cover songs
you could you know oh yeah they cook the
books that way right yeah that's a
that's a good point so yeah um recording
expenses you deduct at the end of the
year yeah you could be like oh you know
um
my time is worth 200 an hour i'm going
to be in the studio you know recording
this for x amount of time i pay myself
that and then if there's profit left
over then i pay the
the other musicians
because it's a business expense right
it is a business expense and you know
you have to pay for the engineer you
have to pay for the pressings or right
right you can order and whatever that
you just keep the receipts for that and
um that's an interesting point i'm gonna
have to dig into that because a lot of
this i would be curious to know more
about that too yeah the conversation is
is
um
i don't want to put you know each of
these bands might have their own reasons
for doing a cover album and
i don't want to blanket them in into
thinking well you know i have more
questions than answers on this topic i
know myself
um
well you know like again with the raven
one that was a perk
for a kickstarter campaign
they
um gave it to people who gave a certain
level
uh
we happened to have given that level and
that's that's how we all wound up
getting it the party animals album but
they you know a business expense would
be they have to pay the bans they're
covering
to like put the up they can't put the
album out before they get the licensing
so they have to pay for the light so
it's going to cost them money which i
guess you're right they can deduct but
it costs you money to do a cover album
like if i did a cover album
um we would go to harry fox which is you
know the the person you go to and say
these are the songs i want to cover and
then they quote you
and then you pay a lump sum
for rights to use that song
but then once once you've gone past that
lump sum you could you could keep the
revenue after that right
uh
you don't know you don't own the rights
you you you you you
okay you have the licensee to use it but
see when you sell albums
whoever has a publishing gets that money
too but you're but you paid for the
right to use it so you don't get sued
yeah
mark has a question here would you say
covering songs is an important part of
musical pedagogy learning to play other
band songs is how i learned to play
guitar
long before i ever began learning
musical theory and i'm going to say
something really quick because scott is
definitely the person to answer this as
a amateur musician myself
playing cover songs is a temptation
because i'd much rather
putter around and play other people's
songs on my banjo or guitar and or bass
and sing them to myself than i would
doing finger exercises or the other
things that i ought to be doing to
improve myself as a musician
right
yeah i mean um no that's that's a really
good point doing cover songs is
different than like an established band
recovering uh
recording them so
like early in my career i played in you
know
it was a tail end of what we called show
bands where you travel the country and
you'd play
covers you get paid handsomely for it
but um
and what that did to me is for me is i
learned some of the best guitar parts of
off the old soul albums i learned some
of the best guitar parts done by session
players and i kind of learned how to you
know decorate different kinds of songs
um get my sound together
you know so these this was an
opportunity for me to do that and a lot
of people you know even great
songwriters will say i learned harmony
and harmony is
how you put chords together right and
they learned uh songwriting harmony from
learning a ton of beatles songs
so you know a lot of us learn our
songwriting craft from what we listen to
so you might not sound anything like the
beatles like you know some of the people
that say i swear by the beatles but they
said oh these chords can go together and
then you start exploring maybe these
chords will go together maybe so i
learning covers is a big thing you know
um
and you know
i still transcribe herbie hancock solos
and stuff because i want to dig in i
guess i'm covering his improvised solo
for other people but i learned
something about intervals that i didn't
think about and uh some the technical
aspect is good so
covering is good
i guess that's a whole different thing
you know like you say like the band like
van halen all these bands were in cover
bands at one time i'm sure
or most of them played covers before
they joined a rock band and
and got big that's the that's the old
model i don't know about these days what
what the young generation is doing as
much
that's that's an interesting point you
know i i brought up at the very
beginning
uh that berkeley school of music has a
page about how to do your own covers and
then put them in youtube and they give
you like five pieces of advice for it
and i think that there's there's
probably
a lot of young musicians who are
planning to do covers but they're
planning to do covers not as a band but
as their own individual thing so it'll
be like them with a guitar or it might
be one of these things where you see
people
and they've got themselves you know in a
couple different
windows and they're singing harmony with
themselves and playing different
instruments and things like that
i don't know that there's i mean i think
there's still cover cover banding out
there right as as a there is yeah the
thing uh because who else what else
would be going on at weddings for
example right
but
yeah and just you know a side note
um one of the casualties of all that's
going on in the music business is arts
theaters now are
primarily booking tribute bands and i
assume
and i said why are you this is an art
center for musicians you know an
original artist
yeah and they said well the only people
bring in the money are tribute bands the
ac drew ac dc tribute band so i mean
do you think that that's
do you think that's like significant of
a a shift
where we're seeing less emphasis on like
i'm going to do my own original thing
and it's going to be within this this
particular established genre and i'm
going to be breaking out in that
and more like well you know the genre is
established now
um i'll just work within it and do
things that people can recognize whether
it be individual songs right a cover or
whether it be like a repertoire
a tribute
you know
um yeah i mean
as far as the you know reference on how
to do a youtube cover
um i'm curious to see if
major music schools are only using what
i call the um
silicon valley model
and if anybody knows musicians or sees
them on
you know we're not being paid fairly you
know spotify well spotify doesn't have
to pay you anything but you also don't
have to be there
and um
are we are we teaching the silicon
valley
narrative or are people getting creative
as they should now the people on
instagram or whatever on youtube doing
covers i mean it's very rare that you
make
even part-time job money on there that
would be huge if you've made you might
make a few bucks you might have somebody
send you a free guitar strap but it's
certainly not a sustainable way to fame
maybe
one percent of the people that do it
which is a which is you know probably
not even that much not even that and so
but you know people like to point to
well so and so came up through there
yeah
i can point to people that won the
lottery well that reminds me though of
something that uh a friend of mine who
scott knows as well uh glitch66 said
about uh the la scene and i think i
brought this up in another
session
um he went from b from being a new york
musician a heavy metal musician
established in new york a bassist and
all of that and he moved out to la in
the 90s and he started looking around
and la was the place to be
in the set late 70s and the early 80s
and even into the late 80s but by the
90s
this is where blitz was really smart he
was like wow there's a lot of people out
here chasing that proverbial brass ring
hoping it's gold and there's way more of
them than there used to be
not all of these people are even just a
small fraction are not going to
uh get something and instead he's like
well i'm probably not going to make it
as a musician out here just as a
musician
but what do musicians need well you know
they need things like food and shelter
well they'll find that from somebody
else he started designing clothes for
them because they all whether they're
making it or not they all need a look
and so that was a really smart thing on
his part you know but the the main point
of that is perhaps the like
being discovered on youtube thing that's
probably tapped out at this point you
know and also what do you get discovered
you know
i have a lot of students that do
extremely well on tick tock but a lot of
people do extremely well on tick tock
and you know i remember an interview of
a berkeley student and the first
question they asked is what's it like to
be famous
and i stopped there and said
is this person famous
i mean even if i go to my music page
and i take the i don't have that many
followers to my facebook music page it
might be about 2 000.
but if greg if you went to each of them
and say do you know scott truly i bet
you half of them wouldn't
it's just something they clicked on
right they're not right these aren't
paid customers these are you know
returning customers yeah well
well
no they're not paid customers in the
first place they just clicked like that
i don't make any money for somebody
liking my page but if they come if it
turns out that they pay attention and
come to my shows buy my merchandise go
to my website and do that stuff well you
know that but that doesn't uh more often
than not it does a transition the
problem is we have a generation of
people
that would rather the attention than any
money they they themselves have no
monetary interest in music as musicians
so if they're gonna do covers they don't
mind as long as they said they got that
60 000 views yeah what does that mean
i mean
in the long run yeah in a way i mean get
rock and roll money is not something
we can look at people's lives right we
can say wow that didn't last long that
advance that you got you know or
whatever whatever it was that was
getting paid out um we all know about
lots of destitute rock and roll
musicians who've lived past their means
but attention in terms of um social
media and likes and
people's eyeballs being on you is even
even more ephemeral than money is right
just because you were being watched a
lot last month that doesn't guarantee
you'll be watched at all next month and
that happens a lot and you know to be
honest the views if you ever scroll
through instagram if a video starts
while you scroll past it
it that counts as a view but i didn't
right yeah yeah so um you know people
pay for sponsors it all comes down to if
you want to get more notice you pay
these silicon valley people that we all
yell at our billionaires why are these
people billionaires because you're
paying them money to give you attention
you know don't blame them
you're i mean like if if if you don't
like them don't use you know
do the old model go out into town go to
everybody's show meet up with people
double bill with someone switch in the
next state with you you know
and you know people that are actually
going to go and pay for the shows
um
and you know this whole thing about
going back to cover songs is
the i don't know like if gray you've
probably heard this before people used
to say well you know if you want to be
an original band be a cover band and
sneak one of your songs and well no
that's not your demographic you're in a
bar
where drunk people want to hear
you know street fight man by you know
the rolling stones they don't want to
yeah
they'll you know so it's you know it's
about audience i would think if you're a
tribute band as opposed to just a covers
band it must be even worse you're never
going to stick in one of your own songs
because it doesn't fit the canon of the
catalog right and i have a lot of
respect for these people that can um
do those things but i i don't have any
interest in it because i'd have to put
my time into say sounding and looking
just like jimmy page
and that's an i that's an odd identity
thing for me but you know
more power to the people that are doing
it because they're making a lot of money
they're doing something right that would
be like if i as a philosophy professor
um were to so i'm teaching like say
aristotle if i had to like look like
aristotle and sound like him coming in
you know
well if you did like yeah if all of your
lectures
were you dressing like aristotle and
then like somebody bringing up stoic
stuff which you know about and you
suddenly have to put out a new garb and
you know act like start limping around
like epictetus or
i mean you know um it's an identity
thing for me and uh
i think everybody has to look why
they're in it and if it's for
that attention
the problem is to an 18 or 19 year old
is unless they have other plans
to do stuff they might they possibly
might be living at home
they uh or they'll have a full-time job
to pay the billionaires in silicon
valley for that attention you pay the
people to you know and then you get
eighth of a penny for
you know for each play yeah
yeah and um you know it's just people
say that's how it is catch up with the
times but it's not how it is it's what
you're subscribing to there's we're
creative there's plenty of things i'm
not on streaming so you're saying
there's different models available but
of course there are one is being pushed
as like the de facto model
and then the others you kind of have to
work at to find or to develop right
yeah i um it's true you know um but the
silicon valley story is hey
you got a computer you got a studio you
got an iphone you got a camera you could
you've got everything you need
everybody's an artist well we all know
that that's not true you spend years
developing your artistry doesn't mean
you're not good when you're young
but um
and you know i i
i'm not on
i make my life
my living as a musician but i'm not on
streaming
um
any of the platforms and i do play out
live a lot for other players and um
and it is very difficult but you know
you're fighting with people that will
i blame other artists you know for
though if if everybody pulled their
stuff off spotify it'd be like it would
be like starbucks having no coffee
you know it's like if you and i made all
the coffee for starbucks and they didn't
pay us for it and we stopped giving
starbucks coffee well they would just be
a building
yeah
that's that's kind of a funny image to
to bring in i mean do you think that
this is like a much bigger conversation
then i do want to bring this one to a
close with something about covers but
at the risk of not being able to do that
let me ask
i mean
that would only work if you could get a
large number of artists to pull out a
spotify and that would take like you
know coordinated action and awareness
do you see that
ever happening in in our current culture
well you know what's interesting
that i keep saying we are in a time
where people want extreme social change
and there's a lot of uh you know for
different reasons
um you know we've seen a year
during covid where there's been
a lot of
strong feelings about things to you know
but musicians don't seem to be part of
that
musicians um
especially the younger ones you know i'm
i'm getting older and i'm i'll i'll be
completely irrelevant one day and but
the ones that are coming in or we'll
never know what time they had to pay for
an album never have a time where you
know they would go out and see shows
like they don't go out and see their
peers they just you know they'll watch
videos on youtube and it's like well
you're not consuming it so it's not it's
a very different media experience you
could say right
you know it's not it's it's not the art
experience it's kind of like if you go
to a museum and see the texture of a
painting see the actual color
um in the presence of it and it's like
ah you could just see you know some some
blurry photos i took and that's the idea
and it's kind of like well you like you
and i talk about the bass hitting us in
the chest and around the crowd and
having that energy of you know and
that's it there's a lot of experience
beyond just you know
the sound coming out of your iphone or
or your any telephone or through your
airpods yeah yeah that's and that's
damaging to your ears because it's most
of them are mp3s lossless available but
it
takes up too much state space so people
just use mp3 which is
it's like taking the mona lisa and
making a photocopy of it 30 times
you know
so you know the experience is
disappearing which which people in
effect are doing with their phones you
know i i was at the the
um a couple years ago and i did get to
see the mona lisa which is very
disappointing because it's so tiny you
know
and you got to stand in this long line
to get up there it's like you know
cattle cattle car kind of thing
um and everybody was getting up there to
take a picture of it
some people like to turn around and like
take a selfie with it um
but most people were like i will
remember the mona lisa this way i didn't
take a picture of it because i was like
well if i can't remember it you know um
i don't know that this you know jpeg of
it's gonna do me any good
i thought you could go home and google
it
exactly yeah somebody else is probably
taking a better picture right but you
know to be in the presence if you're at
the louvre to be in front of like you
know they have a lot of the french
impressionists in there yeah texture and
just like to see the texture it's a
whole different world and then people
say well most people don't care about
that well it's like saying most people
drink cupcake wine which is disgusting
but you know fine wine drinkers we
should just get rid of fine wines well
there's millions of people that love
fine wines is it the majority no but it
doesn't mean we should take as
you know martin luther king jr called
the soft-minded and make that the
the
uh
the norm the paradigm yeah or that or
like you know what judges what everybody
should get yeah mark says the form of
the cover versus the shadow of the cover
um
so
two different kinds of of imitation and
maybe this is something that we have to
come back to the question of imitation
because
there's there's a lot more i think to to
plumb here so this has been a pretty
free-ranging conversation
uh interrupted at first by some bombing
right and then uh scott getting booted
off for for a brief period um but you
know we thank everybody for for joining
us and for the comments and
questions
and conversation and hope this has been
interesting at least uh anything you
want to add scott
no i i like where it went i like the
discussion and this is the first one
where i have i still have more questions
but we had a lot of theories that could
be possible i like kicking those back
and forth like um
what's you know what's the motivation in
doing this and then i love the halford
story i hadn't heard that one so thanks
for reading that
you know there's there's actually a post
script to that which i'll i'll bring up
uh before we go
so he met joan baez
this is what he said yeah um backstage
at live aid in philadelphia halford saw
baez coming up to him and he and he his
his immediate thing was like oh crap
she is not going to be happy with with
me and then here's what what she said to
him
um rob i just want to say thank you for
what you did with diamonds and russ and
i said well that's really great joan i
really appreciate it that's so cool and
then she said yeah because my son is a
big judas priest fan and he liked your
version better than my version
so isn't that a great story
you know
you got the
intergenerationality in there and you
know uh the difference in genre and some
real graciousness on the part of the
musicians so and that that used to be
you know not too long again that's you
used to be the 70s when you saw joni
mitchell and miles davis talking and
jimi hendrix and you know miles davis or
whatever they all just talk regardless
of genre and they're all kind of like
you know
making you part of the art so that's a
nice moment
yeah live aid made that possible
yeah a crossing of genres so on that
note we're going to sign off
um thanks everybody for joining again
thanks scott for for making the time and
i pledge your insights so
we'll see all of you next time
definitely
you